in this video we will be going over
goody bag number two which is about
electronic transitions
what you'll need are four leds white
blue
green and red and one spectrometer the
objectives in this video
are to understand photon absorption and
emission
apply the bohr model and use the
spectrometer to see sample spectra
the conceptual questions you should keep
in mind are how do
electrons transition to different energy
levels and why is spectroscopy a method
of material characterization
as a reminder the bohr model can be used
to model these electronic transitions
assuming that there's only one electron
in the atom
so right now i'm going to draw my energy
axis
and three different energy levels that
my electron can
pop into so this is one
two and three so let's say that our
electron starts
in the ground state and it absorbs
some energy and can hop to a higher
energy level but in doing so at this
higher energy level it is in a more
unstable state
eventually it will want to return to
that more stable state
and when it does so it emits
energy in the form of a photon so
emit photon
and absorb energy
these different electronic transitions
can be tracked
with this equation so the change in
energy
is equal to 13.6
z squared times one over
nf squared minus one over
ni squared where z is the
atomic number and f is the final state
of the electron and i
is the initial state of the electron and
this change in energy is
in electron volts so remember that these
electronic transitions are quantized
since these energy levels
are not continuous but they're integers
this means that the photon that the
electron emits is going to have
a certain set of different wavelengths
and we can see that with this equation
energy equals hc over lambda
where energy is equal to this change in
energy
h is planck's constant c is the speed of
light and lambda is the wavelength of
our emitted photons
after looking at the red and white leds
through the spectrometer you should see
something like this
notice how for the red led mostly the
red and orange bands are visible whereas
for the white led
almost all the colors are visible
another thing that you could explore
is using your spectrometer to look at
the ceiling lights
and seeing how that spectral would
differ from the spectra that you observe
from your leds
in summary electrons absorb and emit
photons of different wavelengths
because electronic transitions are
quantized by capturing this information
the spectrometer becomes a very useful
tool for characterizing
our materials
you